LISA: Hi, ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome.
Thank you for coming today.
Today, we're presenting a
talk by Professor Tom Nazario
on his recently published book,
"Living on a Dollar a Day."
Professor Nazario is a
personal friend of mine
as well as an associate
professor at USF.
He has done a significant
amount of world travel,
looking at the
plight of children.
He has spoken to a number of
agencies including the World
Health Council.
And he'll tell you more
about all of the things
that he has done with regards
to the plight of children.
This book was definitely
a labor of love.
He's going to tell
you about the places
that they went, the
photos that they've taken,
and what we, as a
group and as a society,
can do to start helping with
the plight of the extremely poor
in the world.
So it's my pleasure to introduce
Professor Nazario to you today.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM NAZARIO: So
thank you for coming.
Let me put this here.
And thank you, Lisa,
for inviting me.
Lisa has been, actually,
a friend of ours
for about five years, and
she donates to my foundation.
So it's always so
important and so nice
to have friends like Lisa.
Let me mention a few things.
The point is that I
do run a foundation.
I also teach law.
I write several books
every year and get
involved in a lot
of different things.
But this is actually a
recent project of mine.
I run a foundation called
The Forgotten International.
And we run it out
of San Francisco
and have an office
here in Palo Alto.
And at The Forgotten
International,
we do four things.
We give away mini-grants
to indigenous organizations
all over the world.
But largely, in
about seven or eight
countries is where we
concentrate most of our work.
We give grants to
organizations that are simply
trying to lift people out of
poverty, particularly women
and children.
And we've been doing
that for, again,
about six or seven years.
Presently, I think,
we fund about 37
different organizations.
So that money comes
from a list of donors
that get involved in
our work every year.
And but for them, we wouldn't
be able to do what we do.
Second thing that we do is
that we send young people,
like yourselves, to different
parts of the world where they
do work for at least
two months a year,
and they work for
indigenous organizations.
They can do-- it's basically
technical assistance
because a lot of
these organizations
not only need money, but they
need technical assistance.
So sometimes, you
build a website.
Sometimes, you teach English.
Sometimes, you do
other kinds of things
at these organizations that
help these organizations get
from a real rudimentary level
to maybe that next level where
they can attract
some large funding
and actually do what's
considerable amount of work.
So but these are kind
of the Mother Teresas
of the world, the little people
who care and give so much
of their time, so
much of their love
to help the poorest of the poor.
Well, we come and help
them do their work.
So that's where we
send our interns.
The next thing we do is we
send supplies around the world.
We send things like clothing.
We send things like shoes,
shirts, school supplies,
computers, medical supplies
to places around the world
who, frankly, these places
have been forgotten.
They are not the places
that have recently
been hit by a typhoon.
They're not the places that
have experienced earthquake.
They're just places-- various
kinds of pockets of the world--
little villages
that have nothing.
They have nothing.
They don't have a decent school.
They don't have a decent toilet.
They don't have any
kind of medical care.
And those are the
places that we go
to because the places that, in
fact, get hit by the typhoons,
though they need an
extraordinary amount of help,
they get that through
the media, and they
get millions and
millions of dollars.
We go to places
that have nothing.
So the last thing
that we do is we
try to bring some attention
to the world's poor.
Just so you know,
at present, there
are 1.1 billion people living
on this planet on less than $1
a day.
That's almost one sixth
of the world's population.
And if you kick that up to $2 a
day, that's 2.3 billion people,
and that's one third of
the world's population.
So our brothers and sisters
out there are extremely poor.
And most of them have
a lot of difficulty
getting through a simple day.
Those are the kinds
of people that we
try to help through
The Forgotten.
And we try to bring
attention to how
they live the struggles they
have, the challenges they have,
the dreams they have
to people around
the world who actually
have the resources
and maybe the time to help them.
Why don't we get ready
for the Pierce Brosnan?
In putting together this
book, one of our funders
is the actor Pierce Brosnan.
And he decided to do
a little piece for us
on, basically, this project.
And the fact that we-- well,
about six or seven months
from now, we'll be
releasing a documentary
based on the making this book.
And just so you know,
we traveled to these 10
countries-- some of
the poorest countries
in the world-- on 4 continents.
We visited thousands
of individuals.
We captured the stories
of about 50 individuals
and/or their families who
live on less than $1 a day.
And we told their
stories about how
they get through that day
in photographs and in words.
Now, the photographs
in this book-- and I
will be signing
books for anyone who
would like a book outside
in a few minutes--
but the photographs
in the book were
taken by a Pulitzer
Prize-winning photographer.
They are absolutely beautiful.
They've already
won several awards.
And they're quite compelling.
In the process of
making this book,
Renee Byer, who's
our photographer,
traveled, as I
said, 10 countries
and took 15,000
photographs-- 225 of them
ended up in the book.
So we went through a
large editing process
to get these pictures in there.
And the stories are told in
and around the photographs.
And so when you
see a photograph,
the story is told around it.
And, of course, there's a
lot of stuff in the book
just about poverty in general.
What are the causes?
What are the fixes?
What does it mean in
the person's life?
So let's see this
quick video from Pierce
on what we discovered
around the world.
So I wanted to spend a
moment talking about some
of the actual scenes
and the people
that you saw in that video just
because everybody that you saw
in that video, there's a
story behind their lives
that's quite important, quite
compelling, and probably worth
telling to people
like us who don't have
an awful lot of experience
with individuals
who live their kinds of lives.
Let's see if I can
get this to work.
Now, I'm only going to tell
a few stories because I
want to show a few
other videos today.
But in Bolivia,
we met this woman.
And you saw her picture very,
very quickly on that video.
Now, she works in the hills of
a mountainside in the Bolivian
Alps.
And she is a subsistence farmer.
And by the way, most
of the world's poor--
about 55% of the poorest
people in the world
are, in fact,
subsistence farmers.
Most of them are women.
And most of them produce,
well, actually a little bit
more than half of all the
agriculture in the world
to feed the world.
So they do a huge
service to the world.
But they work very, very
hard, often on lands
that they don't own, often
on a sharecropping system,
and nevertheless, live
on almost nothing.
She, of course, doesn't own
the land that she works.
She is 80 years old.
She's been working this
land for some 50, 60 years.
And she was very angry at us.
She's very angry
at us because she
said the Western
world has actually
destroyed her crop because
we in the Western world
have produced most
of the warming that's
taking place in the world.
And as a result, she gets far
less rain, far less water,
far less of anything that
she needs to grow her crop.
And now, her beans
are all dried up.
And her wheat doesn't
mature the way it used to.
As a result, she had
to sell her animals.
And now, she is
totally impoverished.
She had five children,
but they all moved away.
She lives in a house with
no heat, with no phone,
with no electricity.
And in the evening, if
she needs any help at all,
she has to walk to a
neighbor's house a mile
away and use one
of their phones.
She, in fact, may have
already died-- I don't know.
But look at her hands.
One of the things that I've
discovered over the years
in traveling around the
world for the United Nations,
for Human Rights Watch
is that I've never
found a woman who doesn't
work so, so hard-- never.
Certainly, her hands
are evidence of that.
In Peru.
I wanted to hone in on Peru
because she actually has
the second most
popular occupation that
the world's poor endeavour
in, and that's recycling.
She recycles every
day with her kids.
And the one on her back is
actually her grandchild.
She had six children;
however, two sons
were taken away by a father
who abused her brutally.
She remarried.
He abused her.
Now, she lives all
alone with her children.
And this is how she
gets through her day--
walking the streets
of Lima, Peru,
and collecting whatever she can.
She walks those streets
for about 14 hours a day,
spends a few hours
getting her kids to bed,
and then brings in whatever
she's been able to find
to a recycling center--
on the average,
probably makes somewhere
about $2.10 a day.
That's for a family of six.
Her children, of
course, help her.
And these children
do not go to school
nor will they likely
ever go to school.
This is at the end of the day
at the recycling center, turning
in whatever they've
been able to find.
And this is their life.
That's when she gets paid.
She then takes the kids home.
They live in a one-room
little apartment--
no kitchen, no nothing.
They eat outdoors, or they
go to borrow some food
from the neighbor.
But that's where they
sleep-- all of them.
That's her oldest
daughter, who's
18, who is now following
in the same cycle.
And this cycle of poverty
is very, very hard
to break unless you're there and
you give them the kind of help
that they need.
By the way, we
discovered over the years
and through the
making of the book
is that one of the biggest
drivers of poverty,
particularly with regards
to women and children,
is domestic violence.
It's all over the world,
particularly in South America.
But in Libya, we found
these individuals.
In Libya, which is
actually the fourth poorest
country in the world,
85% of the population
there lives on
less than $1 a day.
These women come
to this hospital--
does anyone know
what a fistula is?
A fistula?
To repair a fistula that has
taken place in their bodies
as a result of
childbirth or rape.
A fistula is actually
an opening in the inside
of an intestinal
organ that connects
one organ to another organ; and
as a result, problems occur.
In their case, and this happens
to about 400,000 women a year,
they die as a result
of childbirth,
usually from the occurrence of
a fistula that's not repaired
and gets infected, and they die.
Now, a fistula
occurs sometimes when
a child is stuck
in the birth canal.
And since they
don't have doctors,
they don't have access
to medical care,
usually the child is pulled out.
The child's, then, foot
goes through the sidewall
of the birth canal.
And, of course, that sometimes
goes into the kidneys.
Or sometimes, there's a
break between the birth
canal and the intestinal organs.
And when that occurs, again,
unless it's fixed right away,
it's very hard to fix later.
What happens to these women
is they spend half their day
on the toilet because they
cannot control their urine
or, actually, any kind
of fecal removement.
So they can't control it
because, again, these two
parts of their
organs are attached,
and they shouldn't be.
And this is the way they live.
Now, the biggest problem
that they have in life
is not so much that
they live this way,
it's that they're ostracized
by their villages because
of their smell.
Here, they have
developed these odors
as a result, again, of
two attached organs.
They're kicked out
of their villages,
or they're sent away-- far away.
And they live by themselves.
Their husbands take new
wives, and they're basically
forgotten.
So unless they get
this medical care,
they can never return
to their village.
They lose their whole lives.
So they come to these
hospitals to get fixed.
And the problem is it's
very, very difficult.
Sometimes, they go through
two or three operations.
These hospitals
need a lot of help.
They don't have expert doctors.
And nevertheless, in some
cases, these children are fixed;
in some cases, they're not.
This little girl
here on the left,
actually, has a fistula
as a result of rape.
She was raped when
she was six years old.
And as a result of that,
her intestinal organs
are damaged permanently,
unless they can fix them.
Now, I'm going to talk a
little bit about "Back to Peru"
a little later.
And again, those are just
3 of 45 or 50 individuals
we met on our travels
that are suffering
as a result of poverty.
The stories were
quite compelling.
And one of the actual
questions that I often
get when I tell some of
these stories is, hey, Tom,
how can you visit
these people and not
leave them in a better way?
And I said, well, the
purpose of the book
was actually to capture their
lives and tell the world.
And hopefully, the world will
turn around and leave them
in a better way.
We didn't have the resources.
Nevertheless, we
always left something
in the way of a gift
with individuals
that we spend a day
or two with trying
to capture their stories.
And the woman who's pushing
around these children
and collecting
these recyclables,
we left her with $80.
And she fell to her
knees and started
crying when we gave her $80
because she knew that she could
stay in her little apartment
for, at least, two months
and not get evicted out in
the street with her kids
because she now had $80.
And what's amazing is how
little money can really
help these individuals.
We'll spend $80 on a bottle of
wine or lunch with our friends.
And for them, it can really
turn their whole life around.
Now, I wanted to move
from this to actually talk
about this documentary
that we're making.
Now, if you go through
the book, there's
one story that seems to have
captured the eyes, hearts,
and minds of a lot of people who
have now purchased this book.
And by the way, Amazon sold
out copies of the book.
They had to reorder through
Norton, our publisher.
I think they now have some more.
But it's become a very,
very popular book,
and it's doing quite well
all over the country.
Nevertheless, the
one story that's
captured really the hearts
and minds of most of the folks
that have looked at this
book is about some children
we found in Ghana, West Africa.
And I think it's particularly
relevant to people
who work in the tech industry
because these kids are actually
some of the collateral
damage of the tech industry.
These kids live on an
e-waste dump site in Ghana.
They are forgotten kids.
They have been abandoned.
They live on the streets.
They live under a truck.
They live in these little
shacks, sometimes 10 or 12
together in order to
protect themselves.
And they have
almost no resources.
And what they do to survive
is they go through e-waste.
They collect it up.
They burn off all
little plastic,
all of the material that's
surrounding the metal.
And then they try to
collect up the metal that's
in the e-waste in
order to sell it.
Some of the metals are, of
course, zinc and copper,
sometimes even gold.
Whatever they can
find, they'll turn in
and try to survive
on that money.
Some little kids only make maybe
$0.10 a day, maybe $0.15 a day.
The bigger kids get some
of the more valuable stuff.
But that's how they survive.
I wanted to show you a little
video out of our documentary
that will be coming out
next year about these kids.
Well, these are
the kinds of things
that you see when
you travel the world.
And I've been traveling the
world now for maybe 20 years.
And when I first started
doing this and going off
to developing
countries, I actually
had to come home and
sometimes go through therapy
just because it's so difficult.
And for quite a while,
I worked with the UN
and had to actually
go to countries
and do reports on the
treatment of children based
on the International Convention
on the Rights of the Child
because, as you
might have gathered,
I'm actually a lawyer.
I teach at law school.
So it's all been hard,
particularly when
you see things that
impact on children.
That's probably the hardest.
And I could tell you
some of horror stories,
but that's not the
point of today.
And in fact, I've
actually given up
on telling a lot
of horror stories
because people got
too bummed out.
And people told me to stop.
But I would like to try to
spend a moment emphasizing
why poverty and global
poverty is so important.
And the first reason
is that poverty kills.
And in fact, poverty
kills more people
in this world than
any other thing.
And it actually used to
be worse than it is today.
Things are getting better.
But on any given
day, 18,000 children
die as a result of
being too poor to live.
They have no medical
care, or they
can't get to a doctor
in time to be saved.
They get no immunizations.
They die from diseases that
they shouldn't be dying from
or something else.
Another big killer
is, of course,
simple hunger and starvation.
However, if we take that to a
higher level and say, OK, well,
what about adults and kids?
Another way to look
at this is if we
look at the poorest countries in
the world, the average lifespan
of someone in that country
is about 39, 40, 41 years.
If we look at the richest
countries in the world,
the average lifetime is
somewhere between 78 and 81
years, with Japan being
probably the country
that's number 1 in lifespan.
So if you happen to be
born in the wrong place
at the wrong time,
your lifespan is
going to be about half
the lifespan of people
who are born in other places.
So the truth of the
matter is that--
and you probably know this--
that it's all just chance.
Our big, big part of
our life is just chance.
But poverty kills,
kills drastically,
and sometimes, of course,
kills the most innocent people
on earth.
The second most
important reason is,
as I've mentioned
earlier, the numbers-- one
sixth under $1 a day,
one third under $2 a day.
The numbers are just phenomenal.
It shouldn't be that way.
It really shouldn't.
And if we look at
those numbers alone,
not only do they scare us
but the other thing that's
kind of scary, in fact, that
I consider immoral is now,
not only do we a huge number
of poor people in the world,
but we actually have a
huge number of rich people.
"Forbes Magazine" comes out
with this report every year
on the number of
billionaires on the planet.
And their last report
indicated that there
was 1,645 billionaires on
the planet-- billionaires.
The United States, by the
way, has about one third
of the world's billionaires.
So we have a
disproportionate number,
particularly since
we only have about 6%
of the world's population.
And that's one of the reasons
why most people consider
the United States one of the
richest countries in the world,
if not the richest.
So we have this huge
number of billionaires,
and this huge number
of impoverished people.
And the gap seems to be
getting wider and wider,
not only throughout the world
but in the United States
as well.
So if we look at that,
that's kind of immoral
in and by itself.
And in fact, Oxfam came
out with a report, which
you may have heard about because
you guys are pretty savvy,
came out with a report about six
months ago that indicated that.
And they looked at the
same numbers I looked at,
and actually, we came
to the same conclusion
that if we take the 85 richest
people on this planet--
the 85 richest people on the
planet, which should have
probably fit in this
room-- their wealth
would equal the wealth
of 3 and 1/2 billion
of the poorest
people on the planet.
3 and 1/2 billion
people are, basically,
half the world's population.
So 85 people have as much wealth
as half the world's population.
That's how skewed
it is on the top.
So is that immoral?
Does that make sense?
One of the richest
people in India
just built himself a
billion-dollar home.
He's actually 47, 48 years old.
The home has 27 floors, has
a parking lot for 180 cars,
has swimming pools,
spas, so on and so forth.
I can go on and on.
Six blocks from
his home, there's
a gentleman who
lives on the street.
The gentleman is a cobbler.
He fixes shoes when
people wish their shoes
to be fixed as they walk by.
He has a little brick
stand-- bricks on both sides.
He sleeps, eats, does all his
work on the sidewalk in India,
six blocks from this
billion-dollar home.
We came and talked to him.
And we said, how much money
do you make on a given day?
And he said a few
rupees-- not much.
And I said, what happens if
you make no money at all.
And he said, well,
I go to sleep here,
and I pray for a
better day tomorrow.
What if a better day
doesn't come tomorrow,
what do you do then?
He says, I go across the
street, and you see that tree?
I eat the leaves off the tree.
So we have a person here living
in a billion-dollar home,
and a person here eating
leaves off a tree.
Immorality?
Craziness?
Is this the world
we want to live in?
Maybe not, maybe not.
Maybe you guys will
do something about it.
I want to go to the
next video, though.
And maybe some of
you have seen this.
It's quite a popular video.
It's relatively short, about
4 minutes, maybe 3 and 1/2.
But it also brings this
home to United States.
What about the disparities
that exist right here?
What do they look like?
So since this video was
produced, it's actually, again,
has gotten worse.
The top 1% now own 43% of
America's wealth, not 40%.
But again, many of you
have heard a little bit
about the inequalities
that exist here and abroad.
Well, I know that I've kept
you already for quite a while,
so let me try to, at least,
say a few quick things,
and then maybe sign some
books or take some questions.
It depends on what
you want to do.
But let me try to answer a
question that sometimes people
have asked me.
And they've done it in
kind of tricky ways.
Some people have
said, you know, I
have this friend who has
an awful lot of wealth,
but he doesn't seem to care.
He'll go out and buy himself an
$8,000 watch or $100,000 car,
doesn't think twice about
people who have almost nothing.
And he's asked me,
why should we care?
And if somebody would ask
me, why should we care?
I actually have
four reasons why we
should care about
issues like this.
Let me give them
to you real quick.
And I think I'm going
to go to another video.
But the first reason is
because good people care.
If we think about
all of the best
people in the history
of the world--
the Ghandis, the Martin Luther
Kings, the Mother Teresas,
whoever you put on
the best people list--
they will all end
up on that list
because they've been
caring individuals
who care about other
people, who give
of their time, their
wealth, whatever
to make the world
a better place.
And we're all, of
course, going to die.
So at some point,
somebody's going
to have to write something
on your tombstone.
And wouldn't it be nice if they
wrote something nice about you?
And the truth is that in order
to be treated as a nice person
or be thought of
as a nice person,
you have to give and
care about other people.
You can't get away in life
without giving and caring,
and think of yourself
as a nice person.
It's no accident that the
Dalai Lama wrote the foreword
to our book because the
book is about compassion.
And some of the people that
we fund around the world
are about compassion.
And this is an example
of an individual
that we help in India.
And I think you'll
see right away
this quality of goodness in him.
Try to listen to
some of the things
he says because, frankly, I wish
everybody felt the way he did.
The Joy of Giving.
We actually did a big
fundraiser with the Dalai Lama
called the Joy of Giving,
where he came and talked
about the importance
of giving and caring.
Second reason why we
should care is simply
because it's in our own
best interest to care.
The truth of the
matter is if we make
everyone feel that
society is fair,
that the distribution of
food, medical services,
and everything else is being
distributed fairly, they're
much less likely to take from us
and much less likely to create
revolutions or conflicts
around the world;
and hence, that benefits
us in the long term.
So it's when we start keeping
those things that we really
don't need, not sharing that
we actually put ourselves
in jeopardy.
So the notion of giving and
caring and sharing with others
makes an awful lot of sense.
And you all know
this because you all
have friends that
probably have things
that they really don't need.
I gave a talk like this
once at a law firm.
And this woman came up to
me after the talk and said,
I want to give you a
donation to your foundation.
And she sat down, and she
wrote me a check for $1,000.
And I said, thank you very much.
It's very generous of you.
And she said, you could do
a lot more with this money
than I can.
I would only buy another purse.
Another gentleman gave
me $25,000 and said,
I would only buy another
car, and I already
have 18 cars in my garage.
So what happens when you have
so much more than what you need?
Does that really make sense?
Is that going to buy you a
ticket to heaven or someplace
else?
I don't think so.
So please think about
benefiting other people.
It makes all the
sense in the world.
And the third reason why we
should give and care for others
is actually something
that Warren Buffett once
talked about.
And the truth is that he
said, the truth of the matter
is that we've all been lucky.
And we are in certain
positions, in certain places,
largely through the
help of other people,
or because we were lucky
at the time of birth, even.
So if that's really the
reality, much of what we got
is really a matter of luck.
Bill Clinton interviewed
Warren Buffett shortly
after he gave $30 billion to
the Bill Gates Foundation.
It was the largest
philanthropic gift
ever made by a
single individual.
And President Clinton
asked him, why would you
do such a thing-- $30 billion?
And Warren Buffett
said, you know, I
can live very easily on less
than 1% of the money I possess.
All the rest is surplus.
I, frankly, don't need it.
So please don't make me a hero
because I didn't give away
anything I need.
If you want us to
talk about heroes,
then go visit the
teachers or the firemen
or the policemen in
the world who sometimes
educate our children
or risk their lives
for the sake of others,
or an individual who
may give an evening
out to a friend who
has no friends in
her life or give up
a dinner or the cost of the
theater to help another person.
They have really given
up stuff that they
need and could use
and benefit from.
I've given up nothing I need.
I've been lucky
enough to be born
in the right country
at the right time,
and I made decisions that I've
been unjustly rewarded for.
So please don't make me a hero.
Now, if all of
America's billionaires
felt the same way, or
maybe millionaires or maybe
even people who are middle
class, kind of like us.
We don't need
thousand-dollar purses.
So I think Warren Buffet
tells a story right there.
Much of what we have has been
largely an accident of birth.
And the final reason why I
think we should think more
about giving and
caring is simply
because, as one of the video
said, it simply feels good.
It simply feels good to give
and care for other people.
My last story,
and it's usually I
tell this story a
lot because everybody
likes me to tell, at least,
one Dalai Lama story.
I've worked with the Dalai
Lama for probably 15 years.
I met him a long, long time ago.
I've spent time at his home.
And I've learned a lot from him.
And on one such occasion
when I was in India,
I was living up in the Himalayas
not far from where he lives.
So I came to his town,
and one of his secretaries
said that the little
professor is here.
That's what he calls
me, "little professor."
And the Dalai Lama said, oh,
invite him up for the day.
And so I came up
to his home, and he
was giving audiences that day.
Now, audiences are
meetings with individuals
who come often from
around the world just
to spend a little time
with the Dalai Lama.
And so I sat in the
corner of the room,
and I started listening to
some of these audiences.
And at one point, a gentleman
came in with his family--
with his wife, three kids.
They all came from
Mumbai, India.
They were very, very
well dressed, lot
of jewelry, very good English,
clearly from the upper class.
And they sat and talked to
the Dalai Lama for about 45,
50 minutes.
And they asked His Holiness
all sorts of questions
about, how do you
retain your happiness?
You've had a difficult
life, how do you smile?
How do you laugh?
What is this thing
called global peace?
Can we ever achieve it?
How would we do it?
What is this thing
called compassion?
So on and so forth.
So they asked the
Dalai Lama some
of the big questions
of the day, which
often come to the Dalai Lama.
And they sat and talked.
And at the end of this
conversation, the gentleman--
the head of the
family, I guess--
asked the Dalai Lama if His
Holiness could do him a favor
before they left.
And he simply asked
the Dalai Lama,
could you bless me and my
family before we leave?
And I thought the Dalia Lama
was going to say, no problem.
I've seen the Dalai Lama
bless people before.
Sometimes, large
groups of people.
But this time, the Dalai
Lama said, you know,
I really don't like
to bless people.
We have just sat and
talked about our problems.
My problems are very
similar to your problems.
Your problems are very
similar to my problems.
We're simply just
two human beings
trying to get through life
the best way we know how.
It would be silly
for me to bless you.
In fact, you could bless me.
And it kind of indicated
the Dalai Lama's humility,
which is one of the things
I love most about him.
But then the Dalai
Lama said, however,
if you wish to feel
blessed, go back to Mumbai
from which you've
come and help all
of those people in and
around you who have so little
and suffer so much.
And in return,
you'll feel blessed.
And that's true.
And that's what I
encourage all of you to do.
So thanks for coming today.
If you want a copy of my
book, I'll sign them outside.
If you want to help me
and my organization,
grab one of my cards.
Give me a call sometime.
If you've got an extra million
dollars hanging around,
let me know.
That kind of thing.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]